[Music]
so
guys have you ever heard of the
weatherization assistance program don't
try to read this article
i i couldn't possibly i saw a picture
that was pretty sexy oh yeah it was a
sexy picture
whether assistant program [ __ ] yes so you
are on the same line of thinking
as one of milwaukee's count as the
milwaukee county supervisor
who promoted this old program from 1976
called the weatherization assistance
program because no one was really paying
attention to it and he thought
hey this is a great way to get people to
pay attention to it it has the same
initials
as well be the number one hand i say say
that one more time
[Laughter]
just for those of you out there know
that it's not how we pronounce it
it's how they do it in milwaukee have
you heard that song way up don't you
know
don't you know about the rap dude
the philippines don't you know you guys
see ben shapiro talking about what
no yes it was hilarious what was it it
was
so epic he's like he's like the youngest
old man
ever but there's only you only get
several of those moments in your life
he's like a white ass [ __ ]
really a wet ass [ __ ] really
that's america really like it's like it
is kind of sad that that's one of the
most popular songs so we got a lot of
got a lot of controversy as you might
expect because
some of the older um people
uh living there and some new way of woke
people
because they have depth um right yes
they have the dry ass
oh so they were talking about it's a
song so
vivid and explicit in its description of
female sexual fantasies that we can't
even explain the title
they were getting very offended um why
is that offensive they've never heard
slob on my knob that's why
i don't understand why whereas [ __ ] is
offensive it's like one of the most
gentle creatures on earth a female
is singing it not a man is that really
yeah
i didn't realize that a song about a big
heart dick though there's a lot there's
a lot
there are a lot of that i just gave slob
on my knob
like corn on the cob check in with me
and do your job
lay on the bed and give me head that's
cleverer though than
just wet ass i know right we're just
like they used poetry back in the good
old days or
juggle what you don't find if the whole
meals you know i can just pull up lyrics
we'll just
it's still not a straightforward stuff
macaroni in a pot
that's pretty clever that's a pretty
clever flavor and the to the
the garage line i can't remember the
line i parked that big
mac truck right in this little garage
dude every madonna song is about like
blowing dicks
and getting [ __ ] eaten yeah so i get i
get the art of it but just saying what
has [ __ ]
okay it's just literal yeah should it be
the most popular song in america
no but we're here i like it i love it
i'm into it i was wiping
this was this was the post that he uh
had posted on this facebook he's [ __ ]
with the times and he's clever
thank you he's clever yeah that's
marketing 101. yeah that's hilarious
that's
he's dope and he was just trying to
bring some more i'm up to date
yeah wow eat your communities across the
country mark october 30th as national
weatherization you know what
weatherization day is an opportunity to
hi seymour
yeah and so the weatherization uh the
the lap the wap is it just to like check
your weather
seals and plug up your holes in our
house yeah it's to actually it's to help
low um low income uh households
reduce their energy bills and it
supports thousands of jobs
improves the lives and property values
of struggling citizens and helps reduce
the country's carbon footprint
so if you have some holes in your house
clean holes in your house
i got holes in my house but that is such
a great way to tap into
a an age bracket that wasn't [ __ ]
caring about that at all how [ __ ]
dare he though
the old people in the back hold on side
note to the people complaining you all
know what it is
so y'all want to complain but you
probably listen to the song
old ass know the words stop and they
they know come on they just haven't had
it in a while that's right because they
got that dab
and they're mad because they're talking
about the whap i feel like every
generation though
people getting angry at the music so
it's like what the [ __ ]
but who has the time to write a formal
complaint let's just
old people got the time they do worried
about my grammatical errors if i'm
writing a complaint dude they go to
cocos and they complain
and then they write a letter to coco's
like yeah
and then corporate sends them like a
five dollar gift card and like okay i
think you'll keep my business
there was a tick tock i saw recently of
someone like
on facebook whatever commenting whatever
to like some city right it was like the
city
facebook and was like uh how dare you
guys support blm
whatever and i don't know if it was like
a troll account or a blind bag but it
was like
oh what do you have a problem with the
bureau of land management what do you
like
it's a great organization that helps us
and then the lady replies back
how dare you try to make fun of me right
now first off
ma'am why are you so upset take your
blood pressure medicine drink some water
and go to bed stephanie
so he got written up by several in
several articles and one was from the
journal sentinel
that noted comments such as white male
politician using sexualized black
women's bodies to gain attention
however the person writing it was a
white person offended on a black woman
behalf and then there's some support
that in the comments
one person said ryan i as a black woman
found this to be witty and awesome i'm
sorry that boomer white ladies thought
it best to tell you how to market a
program that benefits all
it's a cool program and the milwaukee
county supervisor thought he had a cool
way to promote it
um and then another woman wrote as a
retired hoe who lives with holes in my
house
i think it's witty and on trend it's
called i'm looking for the audacity of
these people
so he had to give an apology and he i'm
so sorry for having a sense of humor and
being down with pop culture this is sad
he just wanted to bring some attention
to it
he said it worked no longer we're
talking about it he's on world famous jk
news now you want to check if i got
holes in my house
we got holes in our house and you can
get a fit too many holes in this house
the remixes of the song are amazing so
he says my original sharing of this
press release contained an image which
is not
accompanied the original text my
embellishment of that press release was
meant to draw attention to both this
excellent program
and to a song which at its core message
was about empowerment reclaiming and
destigmatization
it landed badly i'm deeply sorry that
this added burdens of time and emotion
to the exceptional staff that run this
program
and i hope that no one has mistaken my
condolences hr were like working really
hard on that letter like they
they found that was really lost some
sleep though you could tell
like oh you feel bad for the guys it was
mostly um
because the people that work on the
program were fielding all of the
complaints
and so he felt bad that they were like
having to deal with all this backlash
and getting yelled at
and stuff i appreciate people that come
off their high horse to
understand what's going on in like pop
culture and try to make it more relevant
to [ __ ] that most of us don't care about
would you ever care about any of those
things
probably not nah and he went and found a
way for us to talk about it
i appreciate people who get offended for
other people yeah
i do you love it the sharons they're the
best man
and actually you're here for the vibe
this what's kind of ironic is this
weatherization program had
hadn't been his chief like concern he
this isn't like the primary thing he's
been working on
most of what he's been working on has
been leading a crusade to defund the
milwaukee county sheriff's office by
denying them overtime and using their
overtime money to fund parks senior
centers and mental health services
you know what even though he had to make
a formal apology it really shined light
on who he is as a person so big shout
out to you
to learn more about him good job clancy
yeah i mean it just sucks that like um
like you're only going to reach a
certain demographic if you
play like so in between the lines you
know
and most of those people so he was just
trying to bring awareness to this
program
it's like that negative publicity is
still publicity and so
you know but i don't even think it was
bad his intent his intentions were not
like the principal coming out the
backwards had like yo yo
he's trying his best he's trying his
best
i can appreciate that i know i wish it
was doing tupac
what is um do you guys have a song
that people use in like high school or
junior high to like relate
has anybody else what do you mean like
another adult was like
yeah well you know what i mean like when
an adult was like oh we got that always
that wow
juvenile back that up baby got back flip
baby got back oh you mean did i have a
math teacher that i tried to do
do you know what i mean like did you
guys have any songs like he's just being
like don't go chasing waterfalls you
know what i'm saying just try to
like find the algorithm of the situation
or whatever and you're like yeah yeah
yeah
who chases it yo yeah like they're gonna
reach us with that and i'm like dude
even we think that song sucks but you
remembered
you remembered that and you've never
chased a waterfall since and i don't
even know what an algorithm is
but you know what's funny though is like
some of our teachers were
like in our in their 20s and how they
were so out of touch
when they're not that many years out of
college but were they out of touch
or were they just making it seem like
they were out of touch
because we didn't know their private
life or they could have never been cool
some of them were some of them were
really in touch and then they were
dating the students
oh no that's so true though mostly guys
though
yes we never had any teachers worth of
dating they were
not one remember we had one um
in my in my seventh grade history class
she was very young
and she was beautiful lady and then we
went to washington dc for our like class
trip
in on spring break and so she brought
her husband and all the guys in the
class that normally try to flirt with
her
um we're like oh her husband's here oh
she
she brought her husband mrs so and so i
won't say her name but
she misses so why'd you why are you
trying to make me jealous oh my god
really my seventh grade history teacher
was like a gwen stefani
and i had a huge crush on me too i had a
huge question question
i i always thought that like every time
she wanted to talk to me after class or
like talk about my knees like i thought
she had a crush on me i'm like i know
you love me so much
because she's like this much follow me i
know you want to marry me i know you
want to leave your husband for me
oh that's where his head went marry me
i'll cook dinner for you every night and
then when it gets scary is the chick's
like yeah i do
oh gosh i do really do that's how all
the teacher
uh female teacher ones go it's always
like
oh that's one of the things did you ever
notice those teachers are it
what's the appeal i don't know i don't
know what to do to the young boys
no no no we know the young boys but like
those
why why the ladies the chicks are pretty
hot like 20
they're very attractive they seem to be
very attractive the kid that's the
appeal but then the other way around
yeah other way around
maybe it's like oh i can still catch
someone young you know what i mean
but she's young a lot of the ones that
i've seen are young
the men seem older the women seem to
yeah it's repression because then
probably in high school and middle
school they really didn't have an active
social life or any of that [ __ ] and so
they're trying to [ __ ] get some of
that mojo going or whatever
definitely a psychological issue yeah
and they want someone to put them on a
pedestal probably oh because we had
nobody at our school there was like no
one to have a crush on like none
none not even all the teachers at your
school right now are like oh
[ __ ] i thought it was [ __ ] like at
least an eight
i mean i had one person i had it like i
had one person i had oh you gave him
some hope i like that i like that
we did have one teacher that was old
and she thought she was fine do you
remember her she was like an english
teacher like every year she was like oh
she was always wearing like she was
showing off her legs yeah she was always
a playboy bunny yeah so she would wear
like stop she was a playboy bunny
[ __ ] school yeah with bunny ears and
then with the fur thing and she was like
she was like wrinkly as hell yeah she
was like a fit grandma
but it was like too much yeah and so she
thought all
all the dudes probably liked her and
then everyone's just like oh god
yeah not even kidding i had a teacher
named miss cumby and we're all like
every time she said her own name we're
like
like because she taught the wrong age
she taught 12 year olds wow
so every time we heard her say her name
we're just like
do you think teachers know that when
they walk into the classroom like yo
this is
this is a terrible name to have yeah i
would have changed my name just like to
our faces
yeah just to get get it over with yeah
what's the best
that's a really good teacher name
c-u-m-b-y
really who has that name miss combi does
[Music]
foreign
[Music]